nous sommes à l'opéra royal du château
de versailles et je suis re compagnie de
jean paul bousser vous avez été au fond
le premier directeur technique moderne
si je peux dire enfin ou de de cet opéra
vous êtes arrivé quand ici pour la
première fois je suis arrivé en 1987 à
l'occasion de la tournée d'atys de lully
qui a fait la célébrité du baroque à
l'époque qui était donné à l'opéra
comique à l'époque et cette tournée
devait venir à l'occasion des mets
musicaux de versailles et tous les ans
la municipalité organisait un genre de
festival dans l'opéra royal depuis sa
restauration intervenue en 1957 et c'est
la première fois où j'ai été confronté à
ce lieu et qui présente la singularité
d'être tout simplement exactement
conforme en tous les cas pour ce qui
concerne sa scène à celle de l'opéra de
paris garnier réplique 7 strictement la
même chose et ça je l'ait compris bien
après par les rochettes de recherche
avait conduite c'est tout simplement
lorsque charles garnier doit achever
l'opéra de paris en 1873 il n'a plus le
temps de mettre à profit des expériences
qu'il avait tenté avec le chef
machiniste de l'opéra de paris pour
achever une scène moderne c'est à dire
que toutes les rues et les fausses rue
devaient être équipés de moteurs
hydrauliques comme cela venait de se
faire à l'opéra de budapest et on devait
faire une scène extrêmement moderne mais
garnier n'ayant plus le temps de faire
ses expériences de commun accord avec le
chef machiniste de l'époque
eh bien il va continuer des traditions
du xviiie série 2 0 et on reprend est
effectivement la même infrastructure de
xviiie siècle mais au lieu de la
construire en bois on la construit en
fait et elle existe toujours et toujours
et donc quand je viens ici puisque vous
étiez à l'opéra de paris
vous êtes dit mais ça ressemble beaucoup
à l'opéra de paris c'est qu'est-ce
qu'elle a été la première le le premier
sentiment que vous avez eue en
découvrant cette salle et scène d'abord
aux as et même au delà puisque je suis
la scène la première fois c'est à dire
que je me sentais complètement chez moi
mes collègues également les machinistes
de l'opéra de paris
nous avions exactement nous mêmes
repères
le système de rues de fausse fourrure le
plateau en pente des cintres en or elle
relativement rénové en à reparlera mais
les dessous conforme ceux de l'opéra de
paris cinq niveaux de dessous 12 mètres
de profondeur à l'opéra avec 15 rayé et
donc cette des deux gigantesques pour
l'époque et pour aujourd'hui encore et
donc les mêmes repères ça ça m'a
beaucoup troublé
c'est ça qui est la première chose qui
vous a marqué peut-être pas perdu en
arrivant
pourtant dans une salle qui a été
beaucoup de choses depuis sa
construction à la fin du xviiie siècle
ça a été un d'opéra mais ça a été une
salle des fêtes le sénat qui est venu
ici il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on aime
qui sont passés dans cette
on va succinctement reprendre une abus
1770 inauguration du raid une salle
modulable donc une salle transformable
en salle de festins salle de bal et
salles de spectacles et ensuite ça
fonctionnait sous tour à tour selon ces
trois configurations selon l'opportunité
des grandes fêtes de l'ancien régime
autant dire qu'il n'a presque pas servis
puisque c'est un théâtre pour
l'extraordinaire qui est en fait jamais
qu'une un appartement le plus du grand
appartement un endroit qui constitue un
palais et qui précisément n'est pas un
endroit de vie
c'est un endroit de représentation donc
ce grand théâtre
c'est comme ça qu'on appelait pendant
tout le xviiie siècle va donc être
achevée dans la douleur et parce que
comme toujours quand on inaugure un
théâtre ce n'est qu'au lendemain de
l'inauguration bas dépêchent de tout
fait vous êtes arrivé donc rappelé que
la date en 1987 en mai 87 mais définit
définitive mais en parallèle dessous
cela j'étais donc au festival de buy way
to hell âgé était l'assistant du
directeur technique et à cette époque là
j'étais j'avais des relations avec la
france privilégie bien entendu et c'est
tout le monde de l'autre voilà et le
centre de musique baroque de l'époque en
1987 souhaitait c'était là cette époque
incroyable s'est fait partie déjà d'un
autre âge mais où en fait en restitution
en restitution des sons du canton ne
connaissait pas c'est à dire un
tempérament inégal quand on est alors
quand même alors qu'istres et puis
surtout un orchestre avec des
instruments anciens ça c'était nouveau
et l'idée était à l'époque certains
étudiants de transformer l'opéra comique
en un opéra barnard de france et ça ne
s'est pas fait et c'était versailles qui
était visé et le centre de musique
baroque à dix resteront cet opéra royal
pour en faire un centre de musique
baroque appliquée aux arts de la scène
alors ça c'est est nouveau c'est une
chose difficile à mettre en oeuvre
puisque il fallait donc une décision
politique très forte
et puis ensuite donner des moyens pour
aller jeu et s'est effectué une
progression
une structure une équipe et ses longues
ça c'était pas vraiment dans l'air du
temps et moi j'interviens en 1989 alors
que j'étais détaché à l'opéra bastille
pour essayer de faire son inauguration d
une douleur extrême des cas ici et donc
je me rappellerai toujours lorsqu'elle
chef machiniste m'avait demandé de venir
de descendre immédiatement pour
m'envoyer à versailles pour superviser
ou tout au moins à orienter les travaux
de remise à niveau de la scène dans le
but de faire fonctionner ce théâtre
convenablement pour en faire un lieu de
spectacle et un lieu de musique
donc voilà comment en 1989
je vais hasard ici où je rencontre le
l'architecte des palais d architecte en
chef des bâtiments civils palais
nationaux qui étaient philippe bigot qui
me reçoit puisqu'à l'époque la scène
appartenait à l' architecture et la
salle appartenait au musée oui je vous
ne vous dis non
et à ce moment là je j'agis comme
conseil auprès de la maîtrise d'ouvragé
et de la maîtrise d'oeuvre pour
violenter les maigres subsides pour
essayer de sauver les meubles et faire
en sorte que ce théâtre devient en état
de fonctionnement ils étaient dans quel
état qu est arrivé absolument pas
entretenu il avait restauré en 1957 mais
il n'y avait pas d'équipé qui à plein
temps ni même intermittents du spectacle
qui intervenait sur la scène donc
l'opéra de paris qui était habituée aux
soirées officielles
vous savez de gaulle rennais je ponds
pidoux etc
mais mi temps et donc à chaque fois que
l'opéra de paris
venet à versailles je me rappelle pour
l'avoir préparé on apportait tout ce
dont vous pouvez avoir besoin
venir de loin le film de chant au cloud
bois on ne faisait jamais confiance
bâtiment et ont une commande de chanvre
était suspecte
on l'a remplacé et a choisi d'apporter
voilà c'est ainsi et 87 je vais faire
alors vous avez dit ce qu'ils avaient
fait c'était de la scène tout à l'heure
pour l'avoir mais est-ce qu'il ya aussi
la toux le tout le mécanisme toutes les
sous sols
c'est l'impression c'était comme ça
qu'on voulait alors la scène donc avait
quelque chose de particulier c'était
d'un mur coupe feu
donc lorsque le président rené coty
donne l'ordre de d'achever l'opéra royal
qui était en restauration depuis 1950
depuis l'après guerre et donc ils
demandent à ce que cet opéra soit mise
en conformité avec un établissement
recevant du public
donc on applique les normes et comme on
fige l'opéra royal dans un opéra donc
bisky l'effigié d'un état salle d'opéra
et bien on applique la réglementation
salle d'opéra et obligations à l'époque
de cloisonner la scène de la salle pour
le public
on a bien compris tout ça je crois que
et l'idéal ça serait peut-être d'aller
sur la scène nous paie vous montriez
voilà dans une prochaine prochain
prochain rendez-vous ce convoi de la
scène pourquoi ce qui a été refait pas
ce qu'il ya eu comme les travaux de 2009
avec l'embellissement de la salle et
qu'elle a fait une salle maintenant
moderne qui peut accueillir tous les
spectacles
on va on va en parler si vous les deux
prochaines fois depuis la seyne dakar
très brièvement donc salle des festins
salle d'opéra et celle de balle juste en
1789 le à partir de 84 10 784 c'est la
salle de bal qui restent plantés
jusqu'en 1836 louis philippe à
l'occasion de l'inauguration de son
musée à toutes les gloires de la france
donne ici un spectacle inaugural
10 juin 1837 ou la salle est entièrement
repeinte en rouge comme tout avait été
vendu à la révolution
les bancaires et les soirs il sera donc
il a restauré façon louis-philippe
ensuite napoléon toile utilisent
normalement mais en 1871 le gouvernement
quitte paris et s'installe à versailles
est ici l'assemblée nationale s'installe
dans ses salles eva 6875 date à laquelle
on prononce le bicamérisme et à ce
moment là on construit dans l'est du
midi se dire à l'opposé de nous sommes
une salle de séances pouvant contenir
les deux assemblées pour élire le
président de la république c'est l'actu
du congrès des salles de cours et avait
notamment les révisions
constitutionnelles donc le sénat après
donc 1875 reste seul dans cette salle et
ce n'est que le l'assemblée nationale
qui occupent ce quartier donc dans la
salle actuelle du congrès et le sénat en
lorsque justement avec l'amendement
wallon à une voix près les votes à
république eh bien on vote la
personnalisation du pouvoir c'est le
président de la république est élu ce
n'est plus un titre comme napoléon iii
et 2015 voilà donc c'est quelqu'un comme
vous comme moi ok ben ali du pouvoir et
du peu de risques m mais le voilà
peut-être à deux peut-être faire ça 2 2
qui sont en fuite
merci beaucoup pour le baiser on va se
revoir pour aller sur la scène et pour
voir cet opéra parce que cet horaire de
magnifiques il faudra aussi qu'on parle
un peu de la salle et rénové de façon
extraordinaire mais on va le faire
depuis la sède annonce du hockey